the key chi family has waited for this
moment for more than three years finally
they can hold their daughter haiwa in
their arms again I'm so happy
just happy and grateful to God nobody my
love they have a lot of catching up to
do
how his parents show her photos of the
rest of the family and she gets to see
how everyone's changed and then finally
how I gets to talk on the phone with her
siblings again Unnithan with Tian Zhu
they've constantly been asking about her
no day goes by when they haven't asked
me how is she does she get enough to eat
where does she sleep on a mattress or on
leaves from the jungle they really
worried a lot about her and always asked
about her I then tried to calm them down
and tell them that everything is okay
that she would return one day her father
hopes that everybody will soon be able
to live together again Yama and don't
things remain peaceful now she can
return home why shouldn't she she can
return home and take her graduation exam
to andhaka Honolulu quarter-million
pavada but that seems unlikely
last October 23 girls were freed from
the militant group Boko Haram but the
government still has the girls in its
care in the capital some parents
complain that they hardly get access to
their own daughters a government
spokesperson on Nigerian television
offered this explanation ever since that
the most important thing for the country
is this girls must be of security
interest in the first instance who knows
among them maybe some of them may have
returned radicalized and then but listen
them you know to the mainstream might
pose a danger itself to the society yeah
my head I you think Boko Haram recently
released a video supposedly showing four
of the kidnapped girls from chibok in it
they pledged loyalty to Boko Haram and
refused to return home observers though
are warning against placing the girls
under suspicion instead they say their
family should be brought in to play a
greater role it is not acceptable that
they should be kept away from family
friends or relations for so long I don't
see any justification for that and the
reasons given by government are not
sufficient for me how his parents
meanwhile can only guess what she has
gone through in the past three years
all they hoped for now is some peace and
quiet and a return to somewhat of a
normal life
[Music]